robert ménard persona non grata au
sommet mondial de l'information qui se
tient à tunis le secrétaire général de
reporters sans frontières a été refoulé
alors qu'il venait de se poser sur le
sol tunisien tunis avant qu'une
instruction judiciaire en cours contre
lui
l'incident ternit un peu plus l'image de
se souvenait très controversé ch kovacs
atmosphère très tendue à l'aéroport de
tunis robert ménard le président de
reporters sans frontières vient d'être
refoulés par les autorités tunisiennes
bloqué dans son avion d'air france
il explique par téléphone ce qui lui est
arrivé militant des droits de l'homme
cette journaliste tunisienne crie son
indignation
c'est très grave parce que c'est pas
simplement les autorités tunisiennes qui
font acte de tora charisme encore une
fois c'est les nations unies qui sont
les règles et des nations unies sont
violés le sens de conférences se trouve
à 15 km de là totalement quadrillé par
la police
quasiment coupée du monde à l'intérieur
c'est la grande foire aux technologies
de la communication le président benali
vente son réseau de téléphonie mobile
la chine est en vedette avec ses
portables dernier cri mais les militants
de reporters sans frontières refont
parler d'eux sur ses affiches
il dénonce la censure sur internet
quinze pays montrés du doigt dont la
chine et la tunisie sont des pays qui
qui censure des sites web qui est un qui
ont mis en place des mesures de filtrage
particulièrement restrictive qui
emprisonne les cyber dissidents des
internautes des gens qui utilisent
internet pour défendre leur
leur liberté d'expression soudain le ton
monte un tunisien prend à partie les
activistes il défend sa conception de la
liberté d'expression ne dis pas que la
liberté la totale à mon avis on le
citoyen lambda mais je crois que dans ce
pays on se réjouit d'une certaine
liberté d'expression la tunisie du
président ben ali conteste sur ce sommet
de l'onu pour donner l'image d'un pays
moderne et démocratique
mais aujourd'hui à tunis technologies et
libertés n'avance pas vraiment au même
rythme